hello everybody this is definitely
markiplier here for another three scary
games
ignore the symbol on my head
we're about to have a blast with this
three scary games video
i hope you enjoy it
this is almost home
now
it's a game about trying to walk home
alone which can be a terrifying
experience
mouse or wasd
okay
okay
i didn't realize it's this late and dark
yeah
pretty dark
pretty late
this is fine it's fine
it's totally fine
everything about this is fine
100
fine
i feel uncomfortable ominous
you feel ominous or the the thing
looking at you through the fence ominous
i don't like the rumble i don't like the
rumble at all
i almost inhaled my own saliva hi puppy
hi
can you never do that ever again i don't
know which way i'm supposed to go am i
supposed to go this way no not that way
i guess i should follow the light oh
blinky
i don't think i should go towards the
blinking oh but here i go
i'm going the wrong way i need to go
through the park
am i sure about that
am i sure about that
am i still moving
no
no no no no no that's not right i need
to go through the park
i need to go through the park i am
literally three pixels there we go
through the park yay
[Music]
are those some kind of holes in the
ground oh i love this movie
these holes weren't here before they
look
hi puppy if that is a puppy that better
actually be the puppy
[Music]
this is
gonna hey
no
no
this is some kind of a maze isn't it
oh no
oh no
oh no
oh no
okay
i can almost see something moving in the
holes don't look in the holes
what's the first rule finding a bunch of
holes in the random
uh lexian could you reboot me real quick
thank you anyway don't look in the holes
mind their privacy
or something like that i don't you know
i don't know what kind of park this is i
don't know how many zigzags
you need to have before it becomes
inaccessible or maybe it's supposed to
be just
a fun adventure for everybody hi who's
there
hello
oh that's not normal even if this was
supposed to be some kind of a sinkhole
that's indicative of a problem i feel
like somebody should be called about
this i feel like i i should call
somebody about this i feel like
something should be done about this but
i guess no one's gonna do anything about
it okay
whoa it's dark here bro
i should close my eyes and let the job i
should
you know
you right best thing to do in a dark
environment in a place you've never been
before close your eyes that way you
don't see the danger coming
okay i'm closing my eyes
[Music]
you know also it would adjust anyway
it would adjust anyway just being in the
darkness it would adjust
that's how your eyes work is that a body
is that a body on the ground is that a
body on the ground in front of me right
i saw something on the ground it's a
body
i collected the body did i just pick up
that body and put it in my pocket
or did that body just vanish
running water
that's good
or is that bad
oh blood river
i heard that i heard that
we love the blood river
uh do you realize that you've not the
smell is making me sick the goddamn
pollution
that god damn paper factory also what
kind of uh
what why is so much gushing seems like
an excessive amount of gooshing for a
river i don't think it should have waves
what in the hell happened here
no what was that what did you just do
don't switch to a camera view like that
no
home isn't much further why is your home
in the middle of a haunted forest
through the park of holes cross the
river of blood
hey oh okay that uh what am i afraid of
the thing behind me or the thing in
front of me that's like taunting me i
don't know what any of this is about
almost home now
oh god i hate my commute
i'm guessing it's the one with the
lights on i'm guessing it's the one
i made it
i'm safe
am i
i mean i made it
what so apparently that was just normal
that's just what you got to deal with
you know it's either that or traffic
that was very good it actually it really
amped up the paranoia the whole time i
thought it was very nice that really
worked out well i enjoyed that immensely
uh so thank you link in description for
that one but for now
moving on
this is
just want to eat
which i know the feeling
been there before a game any i am
pressing any i clicked that is not a key
hi
hello
i want to hit something
what am i looking at
was that was that was that a video of
someone playing a horror game or was
that a video of someone being a horror
game or a movie or whatever you call
them one of those moving pictures i
don't want this room to be dark are you
sure about that i'm lazy to leave the
house besides it's cold outside
are you sure about that hello ah
air what the [ __ ]
i need to go out the boyfriend
okay i mean you could order delivery i
suppose but that costs money okay i
guess i gotta go then do i need to get
anything my keys my wallet do i just
have those on i'm good
no coat it's cold
screw it
i'm out the door
oh god
uh where do i live
what is this what kind of labyrinthian
ass maze do i live in
i don't know which way i should go
maybe that way because the light was on
there but i see like a building outcrop
over here i don't know
do i have a bike or something
do i have anything
i have nothing
no way no way bro
no way bro bro no way bro bro
who's there
who is
it
who is it
all right fine no one's walking behind
you
stupid
was that you trying to scare yourself
or were you just trying to scare
me ah
the
two
the 24 hour a supermarket where do i
live
this is like the back rooms if the back
rooms was in the not back rooms it's the
out rooms the outside rooms is wherever
i live holy hell
this is uncomfortable
okay
okay
hello my month two
dollars
i got
two
dollars
okay so there's
rice krispies
or rice i don't like this flavor i was
really gonna go for that one
although now looking at it looks like
some kind of purple nightmare so maybe
not
click
do i have milk
do i get do i need milk i just want to
buy food i already have drinking water
at home
alka gold i just want to buy food well
all right
uh
[Music]
shop is equipped with cctv
great what did i pay for it
is it one of those like amazon nightmare
stores where you just go and grab
everything but there's like 10 bajillion
cameras okay i'm gonna go home now
i'm not even gonna bother trying to walk
into the ether i bet one of you can do
that if you play this game but i'm not
gonna try it
time for that
i'm hungry this is so weirdly
uncomfortable
yo i know these walls were probably
laced placed here out of convenience but
it adds some kind of weird surreal
like unnatural feel to it it doesn't
seem like the perspective is correct
like that for some reason the shadows
here make it seem like an optical
illusion that that's much closer than it
is it's something about it is
i'm new here i don't know where this
road leads
okay
what made you pick this place
it's kind of a nice front
sitting area
okay i just want to eat man i just want
to eat
but i i did i did i have food i have the
food did i need to buy two
oh you're kidding me uh lixian entertain
them with something while i'm uh while
i'm going back and getting put a more
entertaining video from me
right here so that people have something
to watch while i'm i'll move out of the
way well i guess i'm in the top corner
no i'll i'll move out of the way while i
do this you you put an entertaining
video of mine
uh maybe maybe one of the you know
lixian compilations that you made
maybe do that maybe put that there let's
see did you do that that jump scare the
scum scare the skunk come scare the jump
scare with the skunk scare him with a
skunk
embryo why am i carrying oh there's a
face on it excuse me
oh no
oh no what
oh no what oh no you can't just say oh
no
why would you just say oh no
why would you say oh no
bro
wait why is everything getting chromatic
i saw that in the stars
i saw the star was getting a little
chromatic what was in that cereal man
oh this ain't right bro
bro
oh my god
well that's not normal what was that
doing in my house
that's not good
oh it's getting dark
boys getting dark now i'm dead now
what happened i don't know what did
happen
i'm home i guess
wow moon
very bright
okay i'll just stumble back home
hopefully hopefully all the cereal
didn't get crushed in my
ah
i'll kill you
bro
i just want to eat
i'm so hungry and you are pranking me
please i just want to eat
please
hello
ah okay all right try that again try
that again i dare you
i dared you
[Music]
those aren't rice krispies
[Music]
bad ending what do you mean bad ending
was there a good ending i don't know
brew i don't know but that was very fun
that was very fun
i kind of enjoyed that but not bad not
bad not bad had a few jumps had a few
scares uh you know honestly sometimes i
just want an experience that jumps me
like that's really at the end of the day
very good
moving on
[Music]
please note that what you're about to
see is highly disturbing do not
distribute this tape to the public i
think this is going to be something
analog horror-esque
i don't remember what it was called
though lixian
uh
just tell them what it is to say it
enough the least dramatic way possible
thank you
what is this
ah
lexi and i didn't need you
home invasion that's what it was called
[Laughter]
boy i hope you didn't put any effort
into what you just did
the winchester are
hives whereas tyler would say
archives
he did say that once upon a time am i
supposed to
dead
what do i do oh god
is that a supposed logo like a
a gun but it's a bullet is pointing back
to yourself that's weird that's kind of
cool
welcome to black curves many people keep
their gun at home for self-defense
where are you going with this
six in 10 people has gun ownership in
winchester
if you decide to keep a gun at home be
sure the gun is stored safely and that
all family members know the rules about
handling guns
where are you going with this but first
let's test your shooting ability
okay
oh
bang boom bang boom bang boom bang boom
bang boom bang boom
bang boom bang
what's my prize
this is a weird vhs i didn't think vhs
could be interactive
it's a trick question ah that's not me
i'm shooting the gunner who's holding
him husband
bring the dick right in the dick shoot
him in the deck um
okay
why why
would i
why why should i why would i do this why
would i do this i don't have to do what
you tell me to do i don't need to do any
part of this
i have agency in this and just because
you tell me to do something does not
mean that i need to do it
that's cold
i'm doing this not because i want to do
this but because i want to progress the
story is that a good excuse i don't know
why me who have played so many
first-person shooters that are like
shoot them
shoot
the bad guys all right fine
oh didn't do anything
okay not that either how what do i do
shoot oh
where is she
you can't save her
okay
you killed her who
that wasn't a very good interrogation
because you didn't get any information
out of
them civil authorities issued a child
abduction emergency
an amber alert
abduction the manchester county is
asking for your help the suspect is
identified as really winning he is five
foot 10 inches tall
he has brown hair he was last seen
wearing black
she has blonde hair and brown eyes she
is two feet zero inches and at least 20
pounds you love direction heavenly rocky
it was uh descriptions of suspect
[Music]
i would never answer the door
what do you mean what do you mean she's
here what do you mean she's here what do
you mean she's here who she who is she
who's she who she where is here
huh
good thing i trained for this
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] what the frick
scared yeah whatever get over it
why are you hiding under your blanket
i'm not
i'm scared of you daddy
okay what if it's not an alternate what
if i'm what if i'm what if i'm being
overly paranoid what if i accidentally
shoot my own daughter which i think is a
scenario that you're putting in front of
me i'm not going to do anything
i abstain from this inane experiment
this is a vhs
vhs cannot do these things
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
all right i'm gonna go out and let me
say that was my daughter i probably
should have shot that thing i could have
done that better
i don't think i had a cool head i don't
think that i was calm and composed i
don't think that i was very uh
in my faculties
[Music]
oh hey
the bradford psychological issue welcome
to psychological stress tests why i want
to welcome you to your first session you
just did that this test will give you
some ideas about how much stress you
deal with in your life stress level zero
for each item indicate how much you
agree or disagree with the statement i
okay whatever
my remote did i ever give me my gun
you mean my gun do you frequently have
difficulty making decisions uh yes no
yes no yes
yeah
do you frequently avoid people whose
ideas are different from your own no i
think it's good to challenge your ideas
every once in a while even if they're
idiots do you frequently act rude
you frequently
complain to yourself i
look at myself and i see only
magnificence
i could be more magnificent
you uh frequently keep everything inside
inside my house inside myself inside
my bone burnum yes on all accounts
you frequently lie to anyone uh not
usually actually i'd like to think i'm
fairly truthful depends
you say frequently
every
not frequently i'm lying you don't know
what i'm saying truthfully if i'm going
to logic through this yeah i don't
frequently kill my daughter that's not
possible
unless
no
no no no no do you frequently hide the
body
again trick question you're not going to
get me on that one you can i know where
you are
unless i have to move the body
no
you whoop
you know what honestly i don't
know
you know honestly uh you know i'm gonna
say
like big truth i don't
i don't know
[Music]
[Music]
glad i took that stress test i feel way
less stressed than i did before my hair
is turning into a bird
[Music]
oh hi hello this is different uh again
vhs very strange
very
horrifying
system
hello am i ah i'm uh again uh
vhs
ah oh i can't see anything
uh lexian can you turn up the brightness
just a bit what is my head turning into
ah that's interesting
i don't like this
this is very
weird
i am
very
uncomfortable
oh
hi
w-e-g-g
oh i can go no more
is it fine i guess i'll just leave then
i am so uncomfortable
i am uncomfy
i am zero comfort
oh blood great
oh
oh good hi hello um
that's your phone
where did you last seen her last time
she was lying down on her bed
okay i just need you to stay put help is
on the way
can i have your name
amanda green please hurry
help is on the way ma'am
wait i think my back door is opened
my son is not home yet is there someone
in your backyard
i think someone's watching
[Music]
hello
hello
[Music]
well this is um
this is interesting
the remaining footage is corrupted
you're telling me this you don't look
very corrupted
this is um
interesting to say the least also the
music is way quieter than it's been in
the past
this is absolutely one of the better
analog horror games that i've played
this is just like there's something
about the way they're crafting it
together it's just like unsettling it
doesn't make a lot of sense but i like
the presentation i also like the mixture
of interactive elements to it not to get
too analytical in the middle of the
terror but the only thing i have to uh
fill the time
so
fill it i will
[Music]
video evidence case 1333 an investigator
was assigned to this child abduction
investigation a police officer john
remington was sent to this house is
everyone named after hi
guns here
oh
there's a single car in the front yard
okay
there's no response inside the house
the victim was last seen in the basement
do i have to
oh no
zero of 90 to 0.99 what
oh
what am i doing
what wait
why
why
[Music]
the media playback was aborted due to a
corruption problem oh okay
restart why
all right we're doing it anyway
let's try that again
flashing
ah
john remington is dead
[Music]
okay
is that actually then i think that might
actually be the end well
that was terrifying that might be the
best analog horror game i've ever played
that scared me i was scared were you
scared good good good well done darkos
well done very well done
hey
still definitely most indubitably
markiplier here i hope you enjoyed this
three scary games video thank you for
watching and as always
ignore the symbol on my head
bye bye
[Music]
you